souvent café picoler on a eu le
sentiment qu'on en savait pas assez sur
notre invité alors on s'est dit comment
on allait faire pour en savoir plus sur
son travail sa passion son monde et on
s'est dit qu'on allait lui offrir une
émission enfin une émission en raccourci
avec les principales séquences de café
picouly c'est à dire l'échec et mat
le ping pong la passion docteur et le
journal intime et mon invité ce soir
pour ses mémoires du zinc c'est clovis
cornillac
bonsoir et bon choix alors vous êtes ici
pour poltergay ce film alors on va
prendre la fiche parce qu'il faudrait
manqué personnes en plus elle est belle
s'affiche je trouve pas mal pas mal
alors donc levis cornillac julie
depardieu c'est un film d'eric lavaine
il y a duchaussoy quand même le dans
away en chasseur de fantôme quasiment
alors poltergay l'idée elle est simple
très intéressant l'idée qu'un jeune
couple et marc achète le manoir de leurs
rêves problème c'est que ce manoir est
hantée suite on verra à quoi et qu' il
est hanté par des fantômes jusque là ça
va
mais ces fantômes sont gays oui on va si
vous le voulez bien voir la
bande-annonce pour avoir un peu mieux le
climat du film amours on regarde la
bande annonce
[Musique]
et
on vient d'emménager dans une nouvelle
maison en hiver
oui je vais [ __ ] une lampe torche
un temps en temps je vois des hommes
c'est celle de mater cauchois poil
travailler dans quels domaines et
chantier donc vous ne fréquenter que des
hommes
ah oui mais lorsqu'on foule certains
désirent
il arrive que ça se traduise par des
visions ait eu mon père fin de ces
marais je fais quoi
vous avez des fantasmes homosexuels
assumez-vous passer à l'acte peut parler
avant tu fais quoi
je suis actif oui mais dans quoi
n'importe qui dépend
à bonsoir monsieur modena nous sommes en
présence de paul ii reste la crise à 27
ans qu'on est coincé ici j'ai 60 ans une
chose m'intrigue
mais tout appétit cette télé certains
les voient
monsieur et d'autres pas ils sont là là
là nouveau ça il faut réfléchir
ce carnet ya convient de voir la bande
annonce vous qu'est ce qu'on appelle un
acteur bankable vous avez le choix du
film celui là par exemple sur quoi vous
l'avais choisi je les choisis beaucoup
sur la rencontre avec la veine parce
qu'au départ avec le réalisateur eric
lavaine ce qu au départ j'ai eu un
scénario j'ai la chance de recevoir des
scénarios et je reçois un stockage me
dis oh là là ça c'est casse gueule ça
c'est typique de premières actions way
première réaction gellé fois deuxième
truc le réalisateur mehdi voyons-nous
jeu on va perdre du temps voyons nous si
vous aimez pas des choses dans le
scénario on peut en parler on s'est
rencontré pendant une heure et demie on
a parlé et tout de suite on était dans
une relation de travail et du coup voilà
c'est avait fait le même film je crois
c'est pas un film prétentieux il ya une
fable il ya quelque chose qui est qui me
semble sur l'ouverture l'acceptation des
autres la rencontre et en même temps tu
te marres mois chez nous plus mal placé
mais je peux parler au nom des rires
j'ai entendu ça fonctionne sur les gens
ou alors ils ont été très bien payé pour
le théâtre marquise et mais ne vous
inquiétez pas ça fout de savoir vous
connaissez le principe de la séquence on
va maintenant passer en revue les
différentes séquences de tradition échec
et mat alors échec et mat savez c'est
l'occasion pour notre invité de revenir
sur un sujet soit qu'il a touché qui le
fâche un coup de gueule qui voudraient
donner aux quelque chose qui l'a heurtée
ces derniers temps vous quel est ce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui vous a touché
heurter m dont vous avez envie de parler
ce soir il ya des choses wade j'ai
appris qu'ils me font mal cette
journaliste russe par exemple qui a été
assassiné l'un politovskaïa oui
je me dis évidemment tout ce qui se
passe loin de chez nous on a tendance à
juger on se porte en donneur de leçons
tout ça mais est-ce que la façon dont a
été tué parce que c'est quasiment un
polar un mauvais polar ces cinq gars
qu'ils attendent ils ont été filmés par
des caméras de surveillance ils vont
avec elle dans l'ascenseur il à battre
pour lui voler certainement des
documents qu'elle a puisque l on sait qu
elle allait faire des révélations
est ce que c'est j'avais presque dans la
façon dont les choses se sont produites
ajouta votre dégoût au delà de ça ce qui
me choque c'est qu'on veut on va crier
au méchant c'est à dire que oui c'est
monstrueux et je suis le premier à
condamner ça et j'ai du mal pour cette
pour cette femme sa famille et tout ça
mais ce qui me gêne énormément c'est que
on va stigmatiser à cet endroit là
n'auraient jamais le show et notre
succès n'est très concrètement on y
participe et on sait très bien que c'est
pas les russes les méchants c'est aussi
un système
je pense qu'on a aussi noix se remettent
en question et je pense que une femme
comme cette journaliste avait
probablement des choses aussi complexe à
dire qui et qui avaient à voir avec ceux
ci
notre idée du paradis
du pognon et clovis est ce qu'on peut
aujourd'hui ça va être très cynique se
fâcher avec un si grand producteur de
gaz
non je crois qu'on peut pas et j'ai je
prends ce qui est terrible qu'on se
relâche pas c'est une réalité mais qu'on
ne le disent pas ça me gêne ça me paraît
bien dire alors voilà ce qui concerne
notre échec et mat pour ping pong alors
je vous donne cette petite bête de ping
pong
oui voilà alors le ping pong c'est une
séquence très particulière dans laquelle
on donne la possibilité à notre invité
de répondre à une critique négative
quelque chose un petit peu un petit peu
dur
et généralement on accroche les
critiques ici et voyez ce que j'ai fait
la voilà la seule critique négative que
j'ai trouvé sur le risque en dégâts rien
je ne sais rien de trouvé d'habitude je
me régale je trouve des trucs inferno un
fake dur méchant rien alors il ya quand
même un mystère pourquoi tout le monde
aime clovis candidats non je me souviens
d'une d'ailleurs j'étais très
constructif non pas les la crise
enfin dans mon souvenir les critiques
n'étaient pas super élaboré mais je
pense qu'elle n'avait pas tord et moi ça
m'a beaucoup construit j'avais joué en
un spectacle britannicus montée par
alain françon et je pense que j'étais
vraiment pas bon dans cette pièce elle
m'a énormément servi parce que j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses et puis ça m'a
permis de plus aux hôtes est aussi
vraiment un moment charnière dans ma vie
est effectivement le jour de la première
c'était à lyon
c'est au théâtre du 8e à lyon est là le
lendemain
la pièce était plutôt aimé mais alors
moi je me suis fait assassiner par le
progrès par y avait trois journaux à
lyon à ce moment là et j'avais trois
critiques mais qui me tuer et le pire
c'était pas les mauvaises critiques
parce que ça c'est un truc qui te fait
mal hein pourquoi voilà c'est jamais
agréable bon mais le pire c'était la
gentillesse de mes camarades après ouais
c'est à dire quand tu arrives au théâtre
et ça va hélas ce côté ce côté là qui
avait 120 mais oui mais qui est pas
méchant qui est pas toi mais auteur d'un
coup tu dis ton orgueil c'est moi je
suis très orgueilleux quoi il tout d'un
coup ça va donner quoi les congolais
savent away tout ça non j'avais les
boules je voulais surtout pas que non
c'est bien en plus ils disent des
conneries intouchables qui me convient
pas
en tout cas bon je vous reprends cette
balle de ping pong alors on se
souviendra sur ma petite feuille je
pourrais noté britannicus jours à lyon
voilà une mauvaise critique pour clovis
cornillac notre séquence passion
d'auteur c'est une séquence où on donne
un miroir à notre invité et on lui
demande de nous parler de quelqu'un
qu'il impressionne
ce qui l'intéresse qui l'interpellent de
qui avez vous choisi de parler depuis je
dirais six mois ou sept mois
j'ai découvert en vrai balzac d'abord
par une biographie magnifique de stefan
zweig le roman de balzac qui est juste
superbe et la comédie humaine
c'est génial c'est vais assez génial à
tous les niveaux l'écriture mais aussi
la fascination que j'ai eu c'est de me
dire à quel point cet homme là arrivent
à décrypter
la machine sociale là la machine humaine
à l'intérieur des sociétés que ce soit
dans
la vie politique que ce soit dans les
faits la vie parisienne ou en campagne
où c'est
ce type là est d'une justesse absolue on
n'a pas bougé depuis deux siècles
alors moi j'ai ce sentiment aussi très
fort c'est de me dire je suis désolé de
poser alors j'ai ce sentiment très fort
de me dire que finalement tout ce qu'il
dit tout ce que je vois comment il
décrit la société geslin près alors
extrêmement prétentieux je n'aurais pas
pu mettre un mot dessus je n'aurais pas
pu l'exprimer mais je pense la même
chose
j'ai observé les mêmes choses je pense
que balzac voilà nous emmène sur un
terrier chez balzac et le livre celui
que vous évitiez parmi toute la
communauté humaine je pense que
illusions perdues et splendeurs et
misères des courtisanes qu'il faut lire
ces deux livres d'affilée dopée et je
pense que à travers cette cette fresque
romanesque
il ya énormément de choses c'est une
bible jeudi c'est formidable que des
artistes arrivent à mettre des mots là
où nous on n'y arrive pas c'est là où
j'ai de l'admiration pour vous j'ai de
l'admiration pour les auteurs c'est de
l'admiration pour les peintres ont les
artistes pour les créateurs pour ceux
qui ont la musique pour ceux qui
inventent le monde depuis rien nous les
interprètes on est des artisans noble
mais on n'a rien à voir avec les
artistes
enfin rien à voir on se sert des
artistes et ils ont besoin de nous pour
pouvoir passer le relais j'ai
l'impression quand je joue je dis pas
que je suis bon ça serai je ne crois pas
on peut pas je ne pense pas les choses
comme ça je sais que suis à ma place
en revanche si on parle de créativité
pure c'est à dire de choisir un cadre de
choisir une narration et tout ça là non
je sais que je suis et je suis un chien
charlot on va vous laisser sur ce mot là
haut le partage pas certainement mais
donc cette passion de l'auteur balzac la
comédie humaine vous avez raison elle
est toujours d'actualité dans son
journal intime
alors ce journal intime et qui a comme
support
cette petite caméra et l'idée de ce
journal intime c'est je vous propose
avec cette petite caméra de 12 ans mais
dans l'endroit que vous souhaitez avec
les personnes que vous aimez ou es ce
que vous avez envie de nous emmener ce
soir je peux vous dire donner une
une chose que rien à voir avec un rituel
voilà on va dire par exemple je vais
filmer pour que vous compreniez
imaginons par exemple que ce ver et
c'est moi on peut imaginer que ce ver
c'est ma douce et tendre
elle est un peu plus petit que moi
beaucoup plus belle ça ce serait mes
deux filles
nos deux filles qui sont jumelles comme
alice et lily est en fait ça par exemple
si on mettait un petit truc au milieu
bah on va faire un peu de promo en même
temps les élèves à dire ça c'est la
table de la cuisine par exemple on est
les uns en face des autres de poupée et
ça ce rituel
vous êtes tous là là on est dans la
cuisine et c'est le petit déj avant
d'aller à l'école le petit déjeuner ou
quand il n'ya pas l'école en a plus de
temps et c'est à ce moment là pour moi
il est
voyez les capitales c'est le petit
déjeuner c'est la parole celle échange
et c'est le moment où la journée
commençait la journée commence pour moi
ça a toujours été une bonne nouvelle et
on va partir à l'école en retard
normalement en général ça se met un peu
engueulé de ce côté là les voies y aller
faut y aller maintenant
allez on est en retard tac tac tac tac
tac évidemment papa il a le beau rôle
donc il fait je vais vous raconter une
blague potache imad al bared papa tu
fais toujours des blagues et puis loi ne
fait plus la tornade fait des blagues ça
se passe comme ça puis après ça se met à
coin en tous les sens et tout le monde
va up en bas de la maison dans
l'escalier en mai les chaussures up dans
la voiture n cho cassé après 4 la claque
papa il va faire son sport voilà
remercie en tout cas pour ce moment très
intime très très très mignon où on est
allé au petit déjeuner un matin chez
clovis cornillac alors en tout cas votre
actualité c'est poltergay donc s'ils
voulaient savoir ce que ça fait d'avoir
une maison hantée par des fantômes gay
vous allez et vous allez retrouver
clovis cornillac julie depardieu dans un
film eric lavaine
voilà clovis cornillac moi en tout cas
c'était un plaisir merci beaucoup plu au
coach je crois qu'on peut applaudir
notre invité
[Musique]